all right heather
heather oh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally um originally
i'm from detroit michigan um i grew up
in brooklyn new york
and now i'm in los angeles and tell me
about your family
um i have a big italian family and most
of them are still in new york or from
sicily originally
um and basically i have three sisters
and one brother
and a single mother how would you
describe your childhood
um turmoil my mother was an alcoholic
and i basically took care of my two
younger siblings
and she was abusive so it was
hectic at most what kind of what kind of
abuse
physical um she
drank a lot and became very violent
and because i was the only one in the
house i was the target of that violence
and you went through high school i did
but i did not graduate
i went to i left house my house when i
was 16
went to job corps um i graduated from
jail corps
and got married at 17 um
and had four children you have four kids
yes
and you raised them i did up until
my oldest was 13 and they got removed
from my care
how did that all come about
i just had a lot of baggage
i came out here and how was the marriage
it wasn't good um
i mean i was 17. my mom pretty much
gave me away to him he was 23 years
old and wasn't
a good marriage at all but i had nowhere
else to go
so i stayed what kind of stuff went on
in the marriage
um a lot of abuse
he he was just very abusive so physical
yeah and mentally
um
it was just not you shouldn't get
married at 17
you're not even an adult at that age and
um is there guys to come to l.a yes
okay
um i left i was
i think i was 20 23
24 years old when i left
um i came out here didn't know anybody
wanted to get far away and
stayed at the mission the union rescue
mission
and that's when my children got removed
from me and
that's when i started with them did drug
abuse i was on hydrocodone since i was
17 because of
i have lupus so they basically just
said you have a terminal illness and
we're going to make you as comfortable
as possible
so they put me on hydrocodone at 17
years old
i go through 80 pills in two weeks at
this point
because my body has built up such an
immune system that
i can't it doesn't um take full effect
with me
and without those pills i go through
withdrawals
and when i go through withdrawals and i
can't get the
um hydrocodone i started i started
seeing a man out here
and he was on sherm i didn't know what
sharon was
never did it before and so
i started with the sherm
um at first it was every now and again
when i didn't have my pills and
then it got more frequent because just
like the pills it
is addictive um
i got to a point where i almost got
kicked out of my apartment
when i lived over i used to live over
here
um where my friend gigi stays now
and i almost got kicked out because me
and him
were doing it so much it puts you in a
daze where you
really don't know what you're doing
you're
almost stagnant because you're so high
you stay frozen or you just freak out
it puts you in a different type of
reality um
recently i did it and i was staying at
the hayward
and i was out front because he's not
allowed in the building anymore because
of our
drug use and i was so high that i really
thought
that i was in this like days that i
thought that
the world was coming to an end like i
just had this like
foreboding feeling and i kind of flipped
out
and i ran away from him and just
a lot of things could have happened to
me but thank god that they didn't
because i was so high
because without my hydrocodone that's
the only thing that helps with my
withdrawals
i get very sick when i don't have them
and
um as sometimes i go back to my doctor
and try to get more
and he supplies it so i
take him i mean i've been taking him
since i was 17.
and there's no way i can stop taking
them at this point because if i don't i
get sick
and i need a substitute and sherm's my
substitute
and i can't stop because without it i um
i get ill like right now i ran out
and i'm trying to get
enough money to get sure that's that's
what i do
so the pills are your preference or the
share the the pill is my preference but
when i don't have them
then you i go to shop right i have that
i've done crystal before but i can't do
that because it makes my heart race too
much
and i become short of breath
my lupus it seems like with the pills
has attacked my body more um i've had a
kidney removed
i've been on dialysis and i don't stop
because i can't
i have to have them i mean there's no
other there's
nothing else more to say i have to my
body now is
i is so addicted to them that if i don't
take it i will be you
regardless how it's affected my body
regardless how it's affected my lupus i
do have seizures
i've had seizures when i took insurance
and i still do it i have to
when your kids are where they're in
foster care they actually got adopted
out
i do see my 18 year old daughter
sometimes
um she knows that there's a difference
in me but she doesn't know
the reason i've not shared this with her
and i won't
um is just
depression on top of everything else
it's my only
escape from reality
so i do it
and there is no stopping and how are you
supporting yourself
i get ssi um
i use that money to support my habit
i get pills from my doctor
he supplies the the hydrocodone
80 pills are gone within two weeks
sometimes a week
because i take them constantly because
i'm so immune to them now i have to take
at least
eight in one day if not more and it's
causing problems with my liver
but i can't stop
and i'm not going to
i have to i have to it's a need i have
to take them because if i don't like i
said i get very ill
i go through withdrawals and
with everything else i don't want to be
sick
looking at looking at your situation now
what do you think what would you point a
finger at
to to the doctors because instead of
caring for my illness they pretty much
gave up on me
and said i'm just gonna make her
comfortable until she dies
they gave me to the age of 45 before my
body gives out
so at this point i'm basically saying
well i'm gonna die anyway so
i might as well be comfortable
so that's why i do it the doctors
they don't care especially when you have
a terminal illness all they want to do
is make you comfortable
and that's it they don't really check to
see how your condition is
they don't see you deteriorating and you
take it as they don't care
so why should you
this has got to be depressing for you
right it is very
and that just makes me want to do it
more right
because i feel like if nobody else cares
why should i
so i do it and i'm going to continue
doing it because
if i'm going to die i'm not going to be
in pain
i feel bad because
my children when they do come of age
and i'm not here i wonder what people
say about me
what they'll hear but at the same time
i don't want to be in pain gone through
enough of that
my body has betrayed me i feel so
and then on top of that i feel like i'm
just alone so
why not make myself comfortable why not
you know ease that pain and because i'm
in constant pain from the lupus and
seizures people don't understand they
don't know what lupus does to a person
especially when you've had it since
you're 17 you have organs being removed
because the lupus is attacking it
and you're in constant pain and the
doctors don't care
and all they want to do is here shove
some pills and take these and
buy they don't even check to see how
your condition is until something comes
so severe that
an organ has to be removed and to me
they feel me you ever look at the
the childhood abuse that you endured and
then the
marriage yeah you had and how that kind
of
that affected me a lot created a whole
series of problems
not with just the drug abuse but with
relationships
um i've been uh the one that i was doing
sharon with was abusive
i almost got shot in the head because we
were so high and he was playing with a
gun and it
got this much close to my head and
i could have died and we were just so
high i just didn't care
um it
it's just a lot
to take in just for one person not just
dementia with my health issues with my
family they i'm very uh distant with
them
i don't really talk to them i'm not
close with them
so i'm pretty much alone my children
were the only thing i had
and when they took that away from me
i just didn't care anymore
so i just take as many pills as i need
to
and when i don't have them i go to sherm
um i've done cocaine before it doesn't
do anything to me
because i guess my metabolism was so
used to the
the high amounts of hydrocodone
really other drugs don't affect me other
than sure because of what sherm is
um so basically it's just those two
things
i've tried other things because i wanted
a different outlet
and it doesn't work with me sherman's
pcp yes
and is that a good substitute for the
pills that you can't afford
because of how strong it is it makes the
pain go away
it doesn't last very long as the pills
do
but it lasts long enough for me to
forget that i'm in pain
you smoke it right yes so a cigarette
it's basically liquid in a very small
capsule
and you take the cigarette and you dip
it in the um the bottle
and you smoke it and that's how it's
ingested
and then shortly after that you go
through a whole
like anastasia moment where you're just
you feel like you're in a different like
a different realm or your mind just
wanders
but it can be very dangerous because you
you're like almost stagnant or frozen
your
whole body everything's frozen there was
a time that i've done it and i was in
the elevator for like 20 minutes because
i didn't realize i was there you
basically your body is frozen in your
mind somewhere else
so you kind of escape your whole body
and you go to a different state of mind
and i'm sure you see that you're in a
very self-destructive yes but at this
at this point in time i'm
i don't care because everyone else has
given up on me
that it made me give up on myself
and i feel as though that's the only
thing that's
um i can actually turn to at this time
and
it's the only thing that's that's kind
of getting me out of my thoughts
and just taking me somewhere else
i have the pain out of all thinking
about all the stuff that i think about
yeah but being being apart from your
kids yes
that'd be enough to break any woman yes
it's the only thing that's taken my mind
off that
do you still talk to your kids no only
my oldest daughter 18 i haven't talked
to my children
in almost 4 years
my oldest son is 20 and doesn't want
anything to do with me
he was took it from me when he was 14.
and now he's 20. and then
my daughter so the drug use started for
you at what age
my drug use started at 23. and how do
you know
i'm 39. so when your kids were young you
were
playing around with drugstores yeah
because of
the pain that i was in i was on the
lupus
i mean i was on the pills before i even
had children
and when they were born i didn't stop
taking them
i continued to take them um i didn't
really start to sherm until after they
were taken though
it was only i was only here a few months
before they were taken
and right after that i was introduced to
sure
and that's when that began and i have
not stopped yet
it's been about five or six years now
since i've been doing
what's the biggest mistake what's your
biggest regret
getting married at the young age that i
was married in
having children with the wrong man
and coming out here
um because before this other than the
pills i wasn't
i had no interest in doing different
drugs and things like that
and then i came out here things happened
and i went full force
not caring about the consequences and
i still at this point don't care because
i just feel like you know
with the terminal illness that i have
i rather die being
not being in pain and and not being
depressed all the time
then to be in pain and
to be hurt emotionally who wants to die
like that
so that's why i do it what's the most
important
thing you've learned in your life
i don't even think i've learned it yet
i don't think i've learned it yet to be
honest
because if i did i wouldn't be doing
these drugs right right
i haven't learned it yet
and hopefully it will i know i'm being
self-destructive
i acknowledge that
but with everything that happens to me
or have had had happened to me
you come to a point where you just give
up
and i think that's what i did
i gave up i came up with myself
in all my life
there's no going back from that
you get in so deep emotionally
and physically that there's a point
where
you can't come back from it
and i think i've reached that point
i've actually tried to commit suicide
more than once
because i couldn't take it and it just
didn't
stick i guess
so i guess i'm just self-uh
self-suspective this way
and there there's no coming back from it
so i do what i do
i'm just hoping that when i am gone
my children won't learn about who i was
when they wasn't around that's my only
hope and that's my only regret is that
they find out how they will have screwed
up so much
what would you say to your kids if if
god forbid you you
something like that happened and your
kids watched this video
that
it's not their fault and
i love them and i never wanted this to
happen
but it did you have choices
you have to live with those choices and
hopefully they make the right ones
because i didn't
if i can't i can't go back
all right heather thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you
i wish you lots of luck thank you
have you been to the women's center
fifth in san pedro right
let's go to blockchain